hey everyone this is luca i'm really
excited to tell you that my course on
the basics of r for ecologists
is up and running so if you're an
ecologist and you're just getting
started with r
and feeling that frustration of the
learning curve and just need something
that
can take you by the hand to really
understand the solid fundamentals of
using r for ecology
check out my course just go to
r4ecology.com
there's a link also down below and hope
to see you there
hey everyone luca here today i'm just
going to give you a really short
tutorial on the basics of simple linear
regression with
r so the most basic linear regression
models the relationship between
two numeric variables and so to begin
with first we're going to load some data
and we'll just
use the data function in our
data to load a data set called trees and
so when we run that line of code
we get these trees data here
so these data represent the measurements
of the diameter
height and volume of 31 black cherry
trees
so note that girth is actually the
diameter at breast height of each tree
measured in inches height is the tree
height in feet and volume
is the volume of the wood in cubic feet
so just for a little bit of clarity
there let's rename the
column names of that data frame and so
we'll just do that by going
name so if we run the names function
that shows us what those column names
are
but within that we're going to replace
those names with
db h for diameter breast height in
inches
height in feet
and volume in
feet cubed all right so now if we run
that
and we take a look at this data frame
again
we'll see that we've successfully
changed the column names
all right so for the basic linear
regression
let's model how the tree diameter
changes
as the tree grows taller so first we're
going to start out
by writing what we actually want to
model
so we want to know how dbh varies
we want to know how dbh varies as a
function of tree height
and so we can write it out just like
that and we can actually use these
column names to make it a little bit
more specific
so how does dbh and inches vary as a
function
of tree height and note that i use this
little squiggly sign here the tilde or
tilde
on my keyboard i'm not sure where it is
on all keyboards but on my keyboard it's
just
under the escape key on the top left
part of the keyboard
and i hold down shift and press that key
under the escape key
to get this tilde symbol and you'll see
why it's important to know about this
tilly symbol in a moment
but you can read this symbol as
is a function of
so now we can look at this statement
right here and say dbh
in inches is a function of height in
feet
and so we can think of our hypothesis
for this regression as being this model
that we've just come up with
another way to think about it is dbh in
inches
is the y variable height in feet is the
x variable
and so the y variable or dbh in inches
is also
the dependent or the response variable
and so we can say
how does the y variable depend or
respond
to the x variable now it's also
important to note that we're not drawing
any conclusions about the causal
relationship between dbh and tree height
the linear regression analysis simply
allows us to test the correlation or
association of these two variables
but doesn't really tell us about what is
affecting what
so let's begin by visualizing the
relationship
of dbh and height and so the neat thing
is we can use
this formula here this this is a
function of this
to make the plot as well so we'll just
use the plot function and then we'll say
dbh in inches is a function of whenever
i say is a function of it'll refer to
this tilde symbol
deviation inches is a function of height
in feet
and then we'll add one more argument
here indicating the data set that this
comes from
so or the data frame
data equals trees and so let's run this
line of code
and there we have it a simple plot
showing the relationship
between dbh on the y-axis remember dbh
was the y variable here
and height in feet on the x-axis so as
height changes so does dbh apparently so
it looks like there might be some kind
of positive relationship there
but that's what the linear regression is
for let's see if there is actually a
significant relationship there
also actually before we move on i'm not
a big fan of these open circles i think
it looks a little better when the
circles are closed unless you have a lot
of overlapping points
for example here we have two overlapping
points which might be harder to see if
the circles are filled in
but i think that's a small enough
sacrifice to make this plot look a
little better
so we'll just add in one more argument
here going pch
equals 16 and that'll just make the
points filled in
there we go so to do the regression
analysis
all we have to do is actually take the
contents of this plot function
and put it inside an lm function which
stands for linear model
so we'll just copy this
and we also have to refer to the data so
we'll add this in as well
and we're not actually plotting anything
so we don't need this this pch parameter
here
but now if we run this
we get some of the results of the model
we actually get the
estimate for the coefficient for the
intercept
and the slope as it's affected by height
in this model so it's not a lot to work
with yet
but we can save this as its own object
so we'll just call it
mod and then we can apply the
summary function to mod
and when we run that we get some more
interesting information here
so first we can see the distribution of
the residuals or the unexplained
variation in the model
with the minimum value of the residual
the maximum the median
and the first quartile and third
quartile range
but below that it gets more interesting
here we have a table of the coefficients
so again before
when we without running the summary
function we just got this value for the
intercept coefficient
and the slope coefficient how height is
associated with dbh
then in this second column we have the
standard error
around that estimate of the coefficient
then we have the test statistic in this
case a t value for each of these
estimates and finally maybe what
everyone's really wanting to look for
is the p-value or the significance of
each of these
coefficients so to think about these
coefficients
and what the significance means think of
it as
what a linear model actually is a linear
model is simply
y equals a plus
b x so to model a straight line or a
linear
line as is described by a linear model
you need two coefficients first you have
this
intercept value or the a in this case
which represents where the line crosses
over
zero and then you have this
b coefficient or the slope coefficient
which which is multiplied by
x to show you the rate at which that
line or the angle at which that line
changes with respect to x so what a
linear regression actually does
is it tries to optimize the value of the
intercept and the slope to create a line
that
best describes this relationship of
points between
height and dbh and then we can use a
statistical test to see if these
coefficients are actually significantly
different from zero
so after this little table here we have
a little bit more information here we've
got
well we've got these significant codes
which are just these
asterisk symbols placed at the end of
the p-value to quickly visualize which
of these might be statistically
significant but then down here we have
the residual standard error
which indicates the variation of
unexplained variance around the
regression line
then we have the multiple r squared
which can be thought of
as the proportion of variance that
in the data that can be explained by the
model so you can ignore the adjusted r
squared for now
if you're just starting out maybe i'll
talk about that in a future lesson
and then finally we have the f
f-statistic and p-value that tests
whether
all the coefficients in the model are
zero so next let's actually
add this best fit line to this to this
plot since we can see that height
is actually a significant coefficient
excuse me the slope is a significant
coefficient suggesting that height
is significantly associated with
diameter at breast height
so let's go ahead and plot that line
just go back to our script here and so
to add a line to this model
all you have to do is run the original
plot that we created so i'll just run
this one more time
and then add in the function a b line
remember the a and the b that i was
using to
to explain how linear model works so a b
line uses a slope and an intercept to
create a line
and a b line actually will take the
the model that we had fit as its main
argument
and create the line from those
coefficients so there it is
that is the best fit line through these
points so finally
let's say that you need to extract a
table with the regression results
so here's a cool trick for quickly
extracting a neat table using the
package called
broom so first you need to install
dot packages
and ins run this if you haven't
installed broom yet
if you have installed it you don't ever
have to run it again unless you
reinstall r on a new machine or
uninstall your packages for some reason
so i'm just going to comment that out
but but after you finish
installing it run
library
broom to load up that package so you
have to
run the library function each time you
want to load up a package but the
install is only
only the very first time you install it
on your machine and then we're going to
use this function called
tidy to create
a table of the results to extract a neat
table of the results from our model
and so now the argument will just be mod
again
our model and so note that this table is
actually called a tibble which is better
than a normal data frame
but that's for another lesson so thanks
for watching this video if you liked it
and would like to see more like it just
hit subscribe below
if you want to see my full courses on r
for ecologists just see the link below
and otherwise i hope you have a
fantastic
rest of your day
[Music]
you